all right it's my phone that
notification
so what did you think about the show
tonight at the vulcan gas company
are you serious it was a treat
how did you live
how did you feel about having to bring
all those people on i felt great about
it you did
put them down there
so far away these [ __ ] teddy grams
i think that's the first show that i've
seen like on a rogan show especially
where
they had you actually like host that
yeah this is it for tony woods
well you you yeah you hosted that but
not
he
like
right
after he went up but i don't think you
you didn't bring on like
yeah
this is this one you brought on like uh
pretty much
most
it was the one time i think that's right
because
you were like how long has he been on
for because tony accidentally ran a
light for like 10 minutes
[Applause]
that bad no it was just like five ten
minutes man so you go first
all right um yeah i mean he was uh
he went over a little bit by two or
three minutes oh yeah but people just
expected him to go along because
people are racist
that's not true i know what time it was
really you know how much time he did
no i was in a moment i was tired again
you wouldn't
go that far over you're 15.
uh hold on we gotta move this i'm sorry
two reds can't be touched ah
nice try come on dude all right
um
it goes in clockwise or counterclockwise
uh it goes to the left
some humber's next
next to his left
[Music]
nine four and eight
so anytime those numbers are rolled he
will get a yield from each of these
resources
that's how it works
i mean it was cool because i could just
bring up the next comedian with like
very little intro
and the energy would already be high
all right dot stop
all i have to do is say their name
and uh then the room would pop
so it's like
it's it was so easy
to host
yeah that was my first time ever getting
to see thompson girl live like i know
he's been down here but i've never
gotten to see him like perform ever no i
heard rogan recently talk about too it
was like they've been trying to get tom
to do a show recently so how do you
think that took any begging to get done
tom said that he hadn't done stand-up in
a while uh what's it called cam said it
was two months the vulcan manager and
they said since his father passed yeah
so everything we heard tonight was
fresh off the cuff from his father
passing it was the first time he touched
a stage since which is phenomenal it was
that good
yeah oh get that [ __ ]
yeah i imagine if anyone's father passed
away you'd be pretty devastated for more
than a couple months
do your the road the road has to be
touching right yeah
yeah
the road has to be touching your house
though
and that has to be two away from another
settlement
two
roads
segments
um
so
yeah that kind of got [ __ ] over there
you did let me move but you made a good
move you didn't make a wrong move
okay
so you're gonna place wherever you think
has the best viable opportunity to get
you the most resources so most people
place next to an eight or a six or near
a place that they think has versatile
resources so like
you get three resources from putting a
house here you get three resources from
putting a house here
using diversity
and the number of dots on each
little number is how probable it is to
be rolled also so if you count the dots
then it's how likely it is so this is
five plus three plus two so that's ten
dots
but here it's five plus four plus two so
this is eleven dots right
and then down here you'll see these
exchange rates
so you can exchange two of any kind for
a sheep
just trying to make sure he wins
that's a terrible spot
it
i don't i don't know where to put it
this is a better spot right here
on a place with a lot more dots and then
i go toward the center if i were you
your turn
wait you went first
yes oh so now you go again
okay so you get to place another house
in another road
so do you think that
the show was like
like a long show tonight it was long but
it was one of the those few long shows
where it didn't feel long
what time did it end
well rogan also it felt like he he
15 minutes yeah he kind of said sure
definitely right so he cut his head
short too right yeah everyone cut a
little bit off it seemed how were you
given the same amount of time tonight
yeah
how long is that usually 10 15 i usually
get 15 but i did 10 tonight right that's
good of you to give it back to the
room you got to pick up these three
resources and this is a terrible spot by
the way
unless he's going for longest road off
the bat
that's strong i don't know what that
means you're making fun of me so
probably so like he's saying you want to
put up the probability of the dots
so i'm not going to tell you where to
play the probability of so
it tells you the dots is how probable it
is so you pick the spot that's three
plus one plus two like this would be a
way better than that right here six dots
no put it back you want it right there
yeah yeah you can play your strategy no
stop trying to explain everything
this spot has
five plus three plus one so that's nine
dots
so you just count the dots all right
below it's your turn is it my turn right
yeah it's phil's turn and you pick up
these three resources you pick up a
sheep a wee and a brick the thing i
noticed though about this show was like
um the audience was pretty engaged the
whole time like i barely had to talk to
anybody like the whole night yeah there
was one lady screaming random [ __ ] out
at any point and then i was trying to
figure out who it was because i was on
the only person upstairs and i was like
oh wait then it was her and then after i
talked to her she didn't do it again oh
god but
i talked to this girl who was her first
time
going to a tommy show ever and she said
there was some person made me out
that was really distracting but i think
like were they making out like loudly or
was it like a bunch of smooching noises
yeah
about that they were just [ __ ]
whispering to each other loudly because
the guy like he was like trying to
whisper but he had one of those voices
where he physically couldn't whisper it
just sounded like someone was playing a
didgeridoo
the tonight was the first time i heard
anyone get warned more than three times
to be quiet on cam yonder and
marcus's accord
they were just at that perfect level
like where you were just like i know
you're reacting to everything but you
gotta really stop being yourself
what a unique mix
it was crazy man we watched some killers
tonight
yeah
shane set was phenomenal
yeah
yeah mark norman had
they didn't want him to get off when
mark was done
which is weird yeah
yeah i mean he did that on purpose
they'll always leave him wanting more
right
what's all those
turn is it yours oh
yeah sorry i i got distracted with uh oh
you gotta replace yourself
okay yeah we should be smoking here
smelling cigarettes no yeah i took it i
took a break last time i don't have any
weight like i would have known i would
have brought something yeah i took a
break last time while he was trying to
figure out the overlapping cigarettes
but this time i'm afraid he just got it
down not the gate
yeah cigarettes are my main thing too
because eventually i will have to
take a hiatus yeah hans do you have the
same viewership the texas government has
for katan
you're allowed to have as many ship
breaks and smoke breaks as you want to
so you pick up these three settlements
okay
do i have the same viewership the same i
don't know what i said it's not worth
repeating
the same as you were man yeah in texas
you're allowed to have as many i'm
pretty sure it's national but you're
allowed to have as many did you pick up
your second settlement first resources
i didn't pick up my first fellow
resources no you only pick up your
second what's your second settlement
this one right here pick up these three
resources gotcha can run for you do the
same thing i believe i don't know
your second settlement let's go through
this one grass and click yeah will you
do it yet i already told you to do it
a sheep and then a brick
a ball
we're all born
right seven
why didn't you roll that
one they're white yeah and this is me
and mumford's role i'm blind phillip i
can't see anything
don't you see these sunglasses that side
of the box is for you and odds and this
one is clearly for me and phillip and
you're right i can't see my fruit are
you making fun of me for being disabled
it's fine it saves the handover now you
can just pick it up from the box when it
gestures or emotions
or it gives a verbal cue i mean that's
also true about the rule book written
you have to physically say something
so this is the board
um i like the placement
i think that
brown could do a little better
yeah yeah i'm sure i'm sure brown could
do a little better um but it's a good
view i like the camera angle
um i'm green
i have a pretty good spot i have a six
and an eight
so you could say that
i'm doing really great so below are you
going to move the robber oh yeah [ __ ] i
forgot about that
um
let me see
six which doesn't look great
red
red oh wait let's [ __ ] yourself i [ __ ]
myself oh my god you got to steal from
yourself now all right i'm going to stay
you want to move it you want to push it
i forgot it was right i forgot we were
uh because the last time you were red
and i was like i have to stop this man
wait so you still from one player not
all players right no you only steal from
one yeah yeah yeah
don't put it on me
i'm not gonna do that don't you put that
don't put the level on me ricky bobby oh
my god
did you put that in the [ __ ]
regular bobby all right give
me uh
what do you mean give you something
hold out your cards like give me a card
dude what do you want
yeah you gotta hide it right yeah well
i just saw all of them dude i just saw
all of your cards oh [ __ ]
nice
yeah isn't this crazy i have the energy
to set this up at 2am i was pissed the
whole time i was doing it yeah don't be
pissed it's fine why can't i be pissed
what time do you wake up
no hold up we'll tell you the way you go
tomorrow is it okay um what time
probably seven thirty eight
p.m then you shouldn't be pissed
i'm pissed why
just because you guys don't help at all
i helped you set up the board a little
bit a little bit i never heard to help
you set up i didn't want to [ __ ]
anything up and look stupid dude
i sat here and watched you do all the
work i was like
well you took the whole wheat pile
and you were like this is mine now
yeah i was trying to
take all the leads
hans takes one thing seriously it's
katan
it's just a lot
i got new stickers should i show off my
stickers okay oh wait did you did you
ever get that box like we were working
one time i think we got a box shipped
and then i forgot to tell you about it
and then we just put it in the storage
closet and i was like oh [ __ ]
i forgot this whole time t-shirts or
something like that i never got it where
the [ __ ] oh
[Music]
[Applause]
so you came up okay you're welcome i
came up you're welcome thank you
it was my first day of the job
was like put him in this dry storage i
was like okay no i think i said that
yeah
you're at 400 on those two years now
because of us yeah whatever you sell
you're going to be [ __ ] duplic
dupli
who'd you order them from
they don't don't say they might they
might get [ __ ] right i remember
though because they're going to show up
they said it was weird because it was a
delivery for hans kim at vulcan gas
company we're like yeah i guess we can
get it to him yeah what did you think
was happening i signed off from you bro
you signed up
don't tell anybody we tried to tell you
i'm i'm really surprised you don't have
them yet i just want to play the game
here's something you try to tell me how
hard is it to tell me this okay but then
tonight someone came to the door and
they were like i need to get to them so
i'm like let's get into haunts and then
you're like i'm going on in five seconds
to the guy that guy yeah he comes off
stage and he's like i didn't i'm sorry
man i didn't know he was going on like
right now i was like yeah we tried to
tell you bro no big deal well i guess
whatever you want to think we tell
people all the time at the front door
like they're busy we'll we'll get it to
them you know what i mean but they don't
think he wanted to hand it to me and it
would have been a nice moment right it's
just like
not the right time exactly
and now i have like a bunch of like a
heavy ass bag of stickers now and i'm
about to go on stage like okay do i
bring this on stage with me like what do
you want mean i gotta stash it
somewhere in the vulcan right before i
go on stage i saw that tonight i saw the
guy hand you that bit heavy ass bag of
stickers yeah you put it in the dj booth
yeah yeah but you're about to go on
stage
[Music]
he was at my hips i was i was tasked to
bring into you but the moment you said
i'm about to go and see you guys are
really [ __ ] my [ __ ] up by the vulcan
i feel sabotaged
i didn't want to let him get to you dude
i was like i'll get him to hans i'll put
him in the sound but he was like i need
to see him i was like okay you dropped
off stickers for three of the other
people but you have to see hans
it was that's sweet
no that box is it's in the storage
closet like right next right next to the
green room tomorrow
no no no no no there's a storage closet
like you know
across from the office yeah one was like
i wouldn't have gotten it he didn't ask
us either that they told me about the
smallest thing i get a little like
postcard or like an advertisement then
tell me about it if i got a box i would
know about it no it's like oh the door
or the guy the door guy
has to come to let's not ask them you
know like the guy's at the door or
you're gonna walk down on six tomorrow
there's gonna be like 30 people there
that's what i thought
it was so helpless
rocking your [ __ ] merch
thank you underground printing she's
taking it she's taking a [ __ ] off
but i only get one free word that's
truly underground now because it didn't
get to you the first time
it got
a homeless habit that's how you know
it's fashion that's good gorilla
marketing dude are you going to buy
anything below um
oh i didn't know it was still my turn i
thought we were just having fun
uh we're never having fun all right i'm
going to that is serious
[Music]
no i'll wait
that time
[ __ ]
what's up it's a three did you drop
who's the three did you drop my sticker
or is that mine it came out when i was
looking for it
yeah why would you ever let that happen
in your [ __ ] pocket look how well it
stands
dude
am i am i do i have good contrast
you contrast with monday yeah we all
look great right now actually thanks man
i'm a very beautiful person
it's just the angle of the computer
screen
okay go ahead
it's too late
six
you have a six right here did you pick
up your six oh no i didn't
hey man i'm [ __ ] i'm just facing out
because i'm feeling bad about [ __ ]
forgetting
[Laughter]
oh my god my career is over packing
which one's what
so if i roll like
which ones
[Laughter]
um
who's red
me pay attention please
i forgot i was red
all right that's the end of my turn i
was too busy feeling bad about
forgetting your t-shirts dude
oh god man oh my god
i'm glad they weren't sweatshirts
they're safe i'll put them that way it's
one of the rooms you [ __ ] him i'm sure
like a roller door yeah if there was any
room too [ __ ] at the vulcan i'd say
it was that one if it wasn't targeted
with
move it
random should give it a couple weeks of
it move it
so you have seven so now this robber is
yours right
so you get to move it on any anything so
you can put on any number it means that
they won't be able to draw from that
resource but it means you get to steal
from someone who has a house adjacent to
that resource so if you're already
okay so you're stealing from me
what
thank
i didn't you to take it but everyone is
stealing from me i have nothing yet but
that's great
and then can you buy anything with the
cars that you have
here's your buy map so if you have any
of those combinations you can buy
yeah
yeah go ahead i can buy and i you know
what i would like to buy but how do i
buy you just put them down and put them
out dude i would like to i put a wood
and i'll put a clip
a clay down and i would like to buy a
road you can place it wherever it is
that connects to one of your already
existing roads okay
so how easy this game is to explain
it's [ __ ] me up there yes you guys
are you know you're brown
are you colorblind here no if you put it
right here you would block them off from
building anymore i see yeah but then you
kind of build right here but if you
build right here you can build right
here
[Music]
okay
your house has to be you see they're
getting one that's give me a little
point right there all right and now
can you buy anything else you want to
buy stuff
you can't
so then you just pass the dice to below
i could have built this out of my
instead of you ever like drinking milk
oh you gotta build a rug you ever you
ever drink milk when you eat teddy grams
yeah because you're making me thirsty
and i'm not even eating fistful as a
teddy grove you want
you want some water
i think what's no no i'm all right but
i'm just like in the background there's
a party sized thing of oreos and three
teddy grams boxes do you want some oreos
how are you surviving clothes two of
them
fifty-three
and then uh
yeah i think hans you also get wood
right would you roll through the five
i took it out i took the wood good
when did you roll the five because you
had it just now
did i already pick it up and i have a
set on my oh it's all in three or on two
if you don't know
the longest roads after does anyone want
to trade
this road a wood for some
tweets
i'll trade someone would for some weight
i'm good all right i don't want your
weight yeah i don't want your wheat
either all right never mind we're all
running fascist settlements here
pounds you want to trade a wood for some
weight
you have weight i have wood i have wood
too all right
well
just a second ago see because you didn't
know if you could spend or not
are you getting late tonight
you guys want to [ __ ] off
i like that you looked at me in mumford
real quick oh [ __ ] racist okay
look at what i have to deal with
two
and then if you can cheat without
getting caught
all right let me see when your heart
changes your mind and it changes you
keep second maybe we'll see what happens
um
what did you guys think about that
karaoke night that we were just at that
was kind of wild are you done
yeah
it was pretty fun
i didn't get to do my song though like i
i waited too long this time yeah
that's because yonder got kept getting
back to other people i mean honestly
that was better than anything
like just give me the 20 dollars i don't
want to go up
don't pay to bump me up the [ __ ]
character list just give me the money
no they they they deserve that money man
they're running this [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] listening to all these shitty
people let's try to sing it was one
night i saw him get like multiple extra
fast passes like people were dropping
hundreds
to skip the fast pace oh yeah yeah i
think i was you were both they were like
and the mouth we did were like they just
broke like 1400 bucks running a karaoke
night off some fast passes dude
and then they panicked because it was
only an hour left and they didn't know
how to get everyone up but they brought
the people out you know
yeah got nine again
99 sis lost balloons
so what do you think about that one like
bouncer do i get two since i have two on
there yeah okay what is the knee what's
happening yeah clay they want to trade
personally
can i collect one garbage i would have
done that a turn ago right clay for
wheat anybody
what do you think about that one bar
back that like loudly clangs the propane
shut at the end of the night like drops
don't want the mustache yeah
that guy is cool yeah he always seems to
have kind of an attitude
yeah
he's been polite to me every time i talk
to him well
i heard that some girl was barfing
and then he was like you're barfing i
need to kick you out i'm gonna buy
things if you want because you're
barfing well that's a good reason to
kick someone off they're barfing all
over you and you have to clean it up no
she's barfing into the trash can you can
get a clay and it's like it's fine to
enforce rules but like when someone's
barfing your first instinct shouldn't be
hey go out on the street
hey man
if somebody's barfing
they've had enough good for six you get
clay so okay so you're just in favor of
having a short temper and just being
mean to customers
yeah [ __ ] customers what have they ever
done for you what's that give you a
little sustainable business model
all right
but if you're if you're in a bar and
you're barking normally you get kicked
out right if you barf in a bar you get
kicked out i think if i barfed in that
bar
i got seven
there's a way you can kick people out i
can't stand watching somebody yeah you
[ __ ] throw them out on their on their
neck and then uh hopefully they hit like
a cinder block or something and then you
get to watch them yeah but if that guy
is just like looking for you to [ __ ] up
just so he can force the rules of some
real like derrick show and energy
yeah it's free that's pretty much what's
happening
i mean
i don't want to talk [ __ ] about a guy
while i'm being recorded man
i'm not a guy after yeah next week but i
just [ __ ] said [ __ ] that
he enjoys doing that he enjoys being
like a little [ __ ] you know annoying
person that no one can say anything
about if it makes you feel i mean i
enjoy slamming the chairs into stacks
when it's the end of the night at vulcan
dude they used to play that song to get
the [ __ ] out of here song which i used
to love like when adam was still there
uh
who's great all right hans give me a
card buddy
please let it be where you please be
weak ah [ __ ] it's not amazing
wait a second and
[Music]
what are the shhh rates again
depends on your dock
all right wait you just have to have a
road leading to the dock right you don't
have to have a settlement
you have to have a settlement oh never
mind either here
i rolled nine the last two times
seven
oh [ __ ] i gotta get rid of half my cards
yeah let me get it let me see
bring that ass here
what do you mean you get rid of half of
them and then he takes it oh
[ __ ] why does he have to get ready
[Music]
that's how much wood there was all right
dude
what do you want well
no i can't
i'm [ __ ] stuck yeah we trade with
people
yeah my settlement is in the stone age
right now
so what what do i get to do
why not because you picked a terrible
spot
i tried my best to pick it up
would you like to trade anything do you
have any wheats i told you it was a
terrible spot what do you want to trade
for a week um
i don't know now i don't know what the
world i'll trade you in a row
you need
yeah it has people that place [ __ ] on it
right
right but just take the roads off
thank you man also like you're doing my
second settlements right
um
i don't want to do the math right now
are you done
past the dice
i mean don't you think that uh
six the karaoke was like crazy because
they started inside
i thought it kind of nervous
i didn't even know that i started to get
something all right yeah i just saw them
i thought they were playing uh their set
inside yeah they were like it's too cold
no one's gonna want to chill
i said it i did say it sorry
i believe the chat did i say six or you
know okay here's the thing about that
guy at lashkey that i find annoying it's
like he's annoying but it's like it's an
acceptable amount of annoying it's just
like it rubs me the wrong way sometimes
it's like sort of like annoying but not
like super like problematically annoying
at least he's not like you're doing some
bad [ __ ] do you want to kill him we
could kill him you want some wood
um
no i will trade you arrive for some clay
i'll try to do two rocks for some clay
anybody have any clay you want some got
some rocks i need some [ __ ] clay dude
you need some clay all right all right i
guess i'll just pass
unless you have wheat you want to eat
i don't want anything maybe there's no
clay all right okay
all right it's your turn thanks man
so
did you guys see
five um
did you guys see me dancing with some
chicks tonight at last yeah i did what
did you think about it
what i think about it i started drinking
off in the back yeah i was like oh [ __ ]
were you impressed that i was pulling it
off anyone want this here's the thing i
didn't think i did a very good job do
you want you have wheat i need wheat
i'll tell you god i saw you on top of
the table at one point though oh yeah
[Music]
mostly thinking about that moment when i
was at the very front
with that
unfiltered
chrissy and filtered
uh she was a bodacious latina okay i
think we were
debating whether they were real or fake
breasts oh you're talking about
that
that was letting everyone touch them we
didn't know what those were those are
fake as [ __ ] are you kidding me no but
it could have been real
everyone has faith
dude those things look like that's crazy
dude those things nothing everyone the
girls who have tits you show them off
probably molly doesn't have fake tits
but i'm just saying like but those are
gross a lot of girls have fake tits it's
like so common
i'm sorry
those are [ __ ] very very sexy but are
you done wait yeah wait well i'm not
going to give up
please all right um are you done
no those
[Music]
well he said please no with four wood
you can change it if you have a clay
i'll give you a wheat how about that i
don't have clients
are you done yeah okay
we got three yeah i'm on three what'd
you know about this i got some wheat
yeah you got you guys yeah you got two
settlements so you get two clay
what can i get i'll trade you some wood
for some clay right now just one wood
for one one collector i will trade you
for a week for a click i'll trade you a
rock for a clay if you want it's my turn
right now oh yeah [ __ ] i'm not i'm not
gonna get your phone you won't trade me
one week no can i roll the [ __ ] dice
you're not gonna trade me no i'm not
gonna trade you oh dude yeah it's your
turn then i guess all right thank you
stupid but it's your turn
oh my god
you gotta pick it up five and it wasn't
count
[Applause]
[Applause]
no clay you piece of [ __ ]
don't look at my car you got monkey on
that three though i'm not going to take
it
[Music]
there are so many bodacious
sexy sexy women tonight
bodacious sexy women yeah dude
at the
latchkey what do you mean my bodacious
dude personality-wise so i don't know
who the girls were at the vulcan
to the rogan show but they were wild i'm
afraid you get a uh wheat
i love sweet thank you everyone but ari
agreed that they were all hot but yeah i
think those are the ones i saw get off
the golf cart if i'm not mistaken
probably yeah that came in with nick's
dad
yeah dude they were hot right but the
consensus was that they weren't that fun
to hang out with or like they were too
loud or something
um but yeah the boys wanted to mingle
the boys all right i'm gonna build a
settlement
um
okay
rick
why are they asking what happened to the
board good
wait
okay
sheep
and
[Music]
those white guys are not the best
colonizers i'm pretty i just haven't had
a lucky [ __ ] brawl yet i need some
clay
your mind changes your mind
if you need some wheat but you have some
wheat now
and thus
your turn now the score needs to be
updated
yes the turn has ended
hans is there no bella's whipping some
ass
whipping some ass by one point
you got a pretty good thing going
speaking of whipping it there right
yeah i got my ass whooped on saturday
night on 6 30. i got [ __ ] jumped by
six dudes defending the owner of my car
the hrv yeah there were guys leaning on
it and so did you come out and be like
yo boys no i said hey y'all get off my
car they didn't hear me so ball took it
amongst himself to say get the [ __ ] off
the car
no i was like hey get off this car have
you ever seen
my eye isn't that bad though that's why
i'm wearing sunglasses it's not that bad
now i just got a gash above it if you
put a flap on that nose
i got slashed with somebody's keys or
something it's looking really good
what about animals
yeah
why were they so desperate
did you guys
was on the floor bloody bro yeah there
was no fighting i was [ __ ] gushing
blood yeah like out of my focus if you
go to my car now there's blood all over
the headliner the car is dented up so
rude that's why i'm wearing sunglasses
everybody's like oh you think you're
cooler than us so is it because like
they were like in a bad mood already and
they were just like i was like hey get
off my car and then they started trying
to talk [ __ ] and this one guy is like
trying to threaten me with a gun he's
like dude this [ __ ] is registered i'm
like did you just threaten me with the
registered gun you're [ __ ] losing
your life over it was honestly the worst
case scenario no and then and it felt
like getting easier phil's like get in
the car get in the car so i get in the
car and i go to shut the door and then
one of them tries to like get in the
door and hold it open so i just shove
his ass he didn't hold him open he just
jumped in it he was because he got
involved space he's like who the [ __ ]
you talking no i went to shut the door
and the door couldn't close because he
was in it so i just shoved him out of
the [ __ ] door and then
like a half time just had to fight six
people and why did you hop out because
if i shut the door they're to start
hitting the car
oh no not the car yeah i'll heal her the
car can't heal
the car can't heal dude you can just
drive that [ __ ] run them for the [ __ ]
over just [ __ ] you know yeah catch a
murder charge charlottesville then
exactly yeah dude dude [ __ ] that don't
risk bellow's eye because you don't want
to fill up some paperwork no no i i i
miss my own eye i miss my own eyes
i'm just talking [ __ ] did you want to
get right yeah you want this what is it
you need wheat no
if you give me clay i'll give you wheat
what about for two somebody rolled a
seven look at these cards in this guy's
hand two wood
for a clay i'll give you wheat for a
week yes
two one player i will give you i'll give
you i'll give you two wheat for one clay
um
oh
okay
i'll do it
i should have rolled the seven dude
it's not
dice work
the way to dice work like that
if your problems looking crappy than me
[ __ ]
mumford
yeah
you want wood i'll trade you right back
why are you giving him what he wants
because he wants what i have it's all
betrayed welcome to america
i'm having a good time
[Music]
hey do you want the student lines 12
there's no there's 112 so i get a sheep
i'm going to build a road does anyone
want to trade wood or a sheep for
clay [ __ ] your [ __ ] i'll trade your shoe
for clay yeah there you go
no sheep oh no
i got i got the sheep i need the clay
okay all right i got wood too if you
need cleaning what do you say is she for
clay i thought you meant clay
do you want wood
no [ __ ] no i don't want it
why didn't she need wood
you didn't need your wait well i'm gonna
trade down for one uh
one road here
can i still place a house or you can put
settlements where how where roads aren't
even laid right you can come back here
so i wouldn't build it here
go here here right here right here so
build here or here to build here
who's green
me i'm gonna build up there
you're wasting a road
it's completely useless in what way i
mean you can't do anything i was gonna
try to block you from even getting there
i mean if you build here you can build a
settlement right away but if you build
here you need to build another road to
build a settlement yeah because you have
to be two away from my god
i'm done
it's your role
so you're gonna build another road
nine
nines have been the most role this game
okay what can i collect
nothing i can get a rock
dude
you collect three
yeah
look how autistic and socially awkward
hans is
hey
suck my dick uh
psychedelic voyager why don't you voyage
your way to hell
thanks beloved this is what caused you
to almost give me other comics some
screen time it's like okay they're gonna
show up
here you know how easy it is to produce
your own podcast
i don't need this green time i just like
what an honor for you guys i know thank
you hans do you want to get on my knees
and vow to you
that'd be nice i didn't come here for
screen time i came here to win
[Music]
mumford is being a [ __ ]
coveted carrier
you guys think any of you have coveted
uh probably not i might be a silent
carrier though i never knew a week and a
half ago
a week and a half i had covered three
days ago how many times have you had it
twice now
yeah normally i'll just pretend
which one delta or this one uh i think
it was like between delta and whatever
was before it yeah are you done the law
it was just my turn i didn't roll
is it my third ain't done i mean he was
pissing oh he rolled the nine okay then
i guess well i mean yeah it's your turn
unless you want to do something here
whoa
that was it was covered
subtle
was that an authentic noise that just
came out of your head yeah
there was a real cough i might have
covered guys you should you should die
ducking right we just wait for mumford
you could roll right now we could tell
for like this i was definitely wanting
to throw at the show tonight
he kept leaving to cough
i'm like no one who doesn't have cove
but isn't thinking about it that much
you know what i mean
have you all coughed on an airplane
since the pandemic yeah
did you want to what can i do
what can you do can i pick up more cards
no
buy something
would you like
a wood for anything i mean this
that's just that's it i've traded wood
for wood
this is a sign of good
faith that just keeps the grease of
commerce going yeah of course
thanksgiving
right there it's like that's [ __ ]
brian riga joke
uh nothing really good you see some
weird things on the highway like i saw
two logging trucks past each other
i feel like that could be solved with a
phone call
[Laughter]
hey you need some bugs
yeah
well i guess it's my turn
all right that is a eight and eight on
eight all right
i can't believe my shirt's been at the
book in this whole time hey man
so wait wait do i not get this because
the robber's there purchase sizes for
that okay right here
overweight individual are you just you
got this you just have small no we're
doing that
i have excels
do i not get people are
what do you wear uh excel okay no he
wears a double xl and i wear a triple
xxx i want xo do i not get it because
the robbers aren't like no no you get
this and this i almost reached double
like cell territory when i first moved
one of those fancy uh road things that
people keep talking about on the news
let me special order a triple xl for you
real quick and those were like half of
my shirt orders triple h self bugs more
like my mom and dad that's who i am they
need triple xls and i'm like i'll order
them i didn't even think about it
i'm sorry mom and dad
[ __ ] up dude
merch is merges the game dude koozies
are [ __ ] phenomenal you have any
koozies yet
write a beer joke and make yourself a
500 mark it's because it's because texas
people are [ __ ] and they don't want
cold fingers
no it's because we want warm beers
yes
i just keep looking at the sheep on this
card i think that's my old you know i
really like this traveling you have to
get rid of half your cards what get rid
of your card
so i have one two three
four five
six seven cards
seven you have to get rid of three of
them no it's seven is good you have
something like that i thought it was if
you have
seven oh yes yeah you guys have seven i
thought it was if you had seven or more
no
okay i'm wrong what do i do i just do
what you do can i collect cards read
all right
do you have wheat
no wait yeah i'm not trading you [ __ ]
after you stole one of my cards will you
want your sheep back no
i love the sheep card it's a beautiful
card do you have wheat
i can't do anything without weed
anyone have
brick
and what sheep
now i have enough shapes how many fans
do you think you dropped off at
brittany's podcast and how many fans do
you think you picked up at brittany's
podcast
i have no idea
give me a number that you think nine
again if you have nine feel free to
profit off phil again
[Music]
does anyone have any clay they're
willing to trade for wood or sheep
no no
no one has clay
done
uh bumper it's your turn
munford more like bunford
oh my
[Music]
he's muslim he's a black panther
malcolm x that wasn't one of the uh
i wasn't i wasn't raised
yes and no not that type of black muslim
do you worship the prophet elijah
muhammad
no my dad was like my dad told me that
they have some weird thing like when
it's like scientology where there's some
kind of weird alien games
this is like uh
your turn
let's put one here yes sir and
say i really want to know about that
though i need to ask some more questions
it's just an interesting choice i mean i
don't think any religion is correct but
if you're gonna choose one you should
choose one that pisses off the powers
that be yeah so
i think it's a badass to be like you got
yourself a six [ __ ] you and your
christianity i'm gonna do like the
opposite of that [ __ ] it's not really
the opposite they all come from the same
[ __ ] book it's over
but that's not how they see it yeah well
it's all stupid in the same way like if
it's the opposite then it's terrible but
if it's similar then it's terrible
because it's so similar are you done you
gotta pass the dice when you're done
yeah all right okay okay
yeah what if all religion is just an
outdated form of governance
oh really seven that's true all right
who's got who's got wait one two three
four that's when you see oh wait [ __ ] oh
i just [ __ ] myself
all right here we go
all right
all right
wait okay i can't count
one
two three two
where do y'all see religion in 20 years
nowhere right on in the dust diminishing
on every front
right where do you see humanity in 20
years
technology i mean technology is then
everything in a zoo
people people don't wait to do massive
or like a new iphone bro it's [ __ ]
crazy i like to do mass
shootings
we're like the horse
we are a relic though
new phones i mean you're useless without
a cell phone these days
you're useless with the cell phone these
days yeah you can't even text me hey
hans your package has arrived
all right
you want to finally give me your phone
number i'll text you all
i would have told you
you need to have it come in another it's
still for it to be important it's all
the same message it's all text it's
still safe
yeah thanks
and you've got double the supply now
with it double the demand yeah
[Laughter]
okay
i'm antifa
more like
i'm like antifa but with the phone
i was going to say
antifa
that's funny
religious people have the most kids
though
they do yeah the most stupid kids
yeah i mean there's a lot of cockroaches
you guys are just some [ __ ] haters
dude a lot of flies tonight as well that
was a pretty it was
incredible there was a large amount of
insects tonight at the joe rugby i bet
we got griped about it too we're like
it's our problem we're like yeah you
know
[ __ ] with fabulous i should have been
better bouncers being like you got too
many legs buddy
wings
i don't know where where do you think
it's kind of why you think so much you
know it's just a matter of i think i
think the flies
the swarm is like a symbol of
death and the apocalypse and i think you
know it does
i'm done sorry let us know next time
give us a heads up i said sorry before
you said that now would you roll i
rolled a seven
five so can i i can collect
uh yeah you can collect the wood collect
trees
anyone want sheep or wood
i'll take a sheep
what you got
no
what about wood
yeah wheat sheep for wood
wheat
no
what about two wood for one weight
nope what about a two wood and a sheet
for one weight
it's like
done
what about
one sheep for one wood
isn't that
yeah we should we should just not say
anything about the other boxes church
and then wait for me to get that one and
then just undercut him like
set up a table next to him eight is the
number
eight
is the line
dude this isn't the worst game i've ever
played in hands down
so far you built one road i have nothing
you got two points
oh bumford has three because
i'm continuing to build i'm not afraid
i'm happy no we're tied right
yeah you're second place
yeah i'm second place
you
suck this
can be as bad as you guys die or what
you're good did you pass it to me i said
you're good you're not the best what
does that mean
what do you mean just tip the box
it is uh six i get a wood
so i get um i got your wood
when i look at your mom five kiss
okay
i just get trees do you remember the
time you talked about sex in front of my
wear that with that old woman my mom the
bat no
mom remember
when i went off with that old ass woman
no yes and you went to cyberkey and got
stranded in dallas yeah and you were
like come pick me up i was like dallas
does anyone want to drink did you watch
me
yeah well you guys wanted to get out of
there real quick well you said you were
mean to her after she said she wasn't
taking it home though which made
complete sense you were like yeah wood
for sheep
and the funny thing is like people
recognize me at that diner
and they're like hey nice to meet you
and then i sat right next to them and
then i was like you're a [ __ ] and
you're rude to waiters and you're a bad
person
and then afterwards they didn't make eye
contact with me
that's about the time i got the text i'd
imagine are you gonna pick me up
and they're like oh man hans is actually
kind of a misogynist oh kind of
that lady was a mean bugging woman dude
she was crazy she was a succubus that's
what we were calling her that night
i wanted to go into the barn
[Music]
yeah did you say three yeah
why do i get oh because there's two dots
okay
are you done
no um
because you have two settlements next to
it
not because there's two dots
that's here yeah
this one's got this this little house
that's the last right
it's pretty literal like you own a
settlement near that resource so your
settlement gets that resource every time
i'm done
anyone want wood
anyone want sheep
yes yeah wait
no
if you have rock i'll give you i'll give
you uh
wood
you you have wood
anyone have wheat
no
please
anyone want rock
i do want rock yeah sheep i'll give you
how many rock do you have i'll give you
two sheep
on their mind all right [ __ ] it
how did you get the chat to stream to
obs do you just like plug it in i just
press the button it just works
i just spent more time in it
hans knows more about obs tonight yeah
that's [ __ ] my job it says uh [ __ ]
out of here hans is becoming a name go
back to brittany's couch bro
i don't know what that was like three
separate i don't even know what that was
responding to but they got your ass
whatever the [ __ ] they were talking
about i was playing katana at 4 30 in
the morning and i'll tell you you need
to go to bed
you've been recruiting
back to brittany's
yeah the just okay podcast is taking off
because of mom's chasers
what the hell is this f5
come on daddy needs a new pair of clay
six
i'll take a wood
and take out one
yeah two two woods
does anyone have any rock they're
willing to trade for
wood or clay for wood
i'll even take sheep or wheat for wood
at this point do you have any wheat
i have wheat but i need clay
i'll give you one for wheat or no i need
clay any clay
i'll give you cheaper hay or cheaper
wheat for clay right now
i will trade you
actually i'm gonna have too many cards
there man
any super coo any super wheat
does all right well that's a fun turn
everybody it's mumford's turn again yeah
thank you
[Music]
does anyone need any wood or rocks or i
need wheat do you have wheat no i just
asked if you all need wheat 10 and 11
hasn't been rolled
you need what we didn't you know what
the other only options are two and a
three but i still can
you're fat
all right
hey dad
[Music]
how would it be to bring this entire
thing to the battery yeah is there any
way we could have intermission yeah i
want to smoke a cigarette really bad but
also i'm kind of invested in this game
[ __ ] your investments i mean don't you
think it's good to withstand the
temptations
to overcome your inner [ __ ] no that's
why everybody's getting all mean and
[ __ ] because you're going to take a
selfie with me
[Laughter]
it's been five minutes since i haven't
had a cigarette the question is
five minutes
yeah sorry all right
i want to chew off my own nipples if i
don't smoke a cigarette within the next
two minutes
all right uh seven i just [ __ ] myself
again okay good job six seven eight
[ __ ] three
four five six
two
all right well
food
would you want to trade
anything
i can't do it until after i get rid of
right here food
a rock i want to do that too
yeah i know you're right
all right so i'm going to
i don't know if i like or love this i
don't know if i hate or love this table
does anybody have it's nice because it
has texture right but it's bad because
like things don't lie flat on it anybody
having your feet right now no no one has
what are you training for i'll trade you
weak for clay
you know what
you know what i make that deal
you make that deal
that makes you feel
all right it's your turn you never do
that you are always so thirsty for brick
you i don't have any supply to it
i [ __ ] up
nine
nine okay
you want brick rude
for what wait i don't have anybody i
have sheep
in wood and
rock you want a rock for wood
yeah
thanks
do you need any more wood
no
this market's closed but the needs have
been met
have we
unless we
you wouldn't know it i wouldn't remember
i really need a week
this is actually becoming a problem
is there any way we could get more wheat
perhaps if someone rolled that too
eight
eight all right i will take your sheep
dude
you think
joe
went home with that girl
drew mcnamara
oh i i think he did actually which is
surprising i know
does anyone have does anyone does anyone
need anything for wheat
what do you mean
do you have wheat does anyone have one
has to live for food
i need wheat
no one
i know well i need also needed something
else so i'm gonna go ahead and i'm gonna
build a road
why don't you build a round huh nothing
why don't why did i build a road or no i
don't you i you should build a road i'm
going to
but yeah i mean i was surprised but that
girl is like so
so wild it's hard to predict what she's
gonna do i was single in austin for all
of four months and that was more than
enough for me to think i needed another
relationship
but i was also like trying
and being single for four months i was
fresh out of a breakup
so it was
the city provided more than enough
achievement
yeah i mean this is a pretty wild city
it is
i had a couple of dates of women that
made me think of a quick comedy just in
their house husband dude this sounds
weird like that
phil if i get some weight thank you for
reminding me three is weird
yeah two brick you would never think
about it what is that you get two right
comedy and be a house husband no i just
it was one chicken specific she was like
six two and she was a she was a coder
so it was just uh it's like i could hang
it up and then just [ __ ] make the bed
every day for the rest of my life if i
want to why not just do comedy on the
side
well that would be the idea i mean i'd
get out and do my own thing but it's
like i mean you know what i mean
rogan has that bed he's like i don't
even get to pick any of the own [ __ ] in
my house and i make all the money
yeah yeah
mumford's low-key doing something so
anyone want to create any rocks
what do you have
rocks
oh my god wait you haven't got
i got a rock in my pocket i'll trade you
wood for rocks right now
no i don't want your wood what are you
doing so you're trying to trade rock
rock for sheeps
i need your phone
all right you have to almost say i have
this i mean unless you do have wheat or
you could just show your cards like i do
do you yeah he's like he's reached a
little bit of attacking this he's got a
two-point lead on they don't [ __ ]
show myself i i thought you were
supposed to sugar nice it's like public
information
[Music]
no but we also we're used to getting to
bed right now right now i mean yeah a
couple more hours
all right i mean we work at night so
i'll be playing disc golf in three hours
can i exchange anything yeah four for
one of anything four for one okay four
of the same resources
oh you can trade to rock in for anything
okay
let me see
yeah i'm surprised that joe went home
with that girl because i was trying to
get with that girl too i'm surprised if
she went home with him
maybe she just needed a ride
that's a good treat yeah all right let's
just
i think she just let's just say that she
just needed a ride
but don't you think that girl is like
weird
i don't know i didn't talk to her at all
i just saw her when i was a kid
she seemed like a nice person you know
she brought all of her hot friends there
was this hot asian girl that i was
eyeing but she seemed pretty
uninterested in me
all right um
i'm going to let me see
and then that was a really good hot
crowd for that karaoke that was like
really really tintillating it's a good
one man yeah that was packed yeah
definitely someone at omicron
for sure
that was a good thing and then
does
anybody know about it anymore i'd touch
somebody no i'm gonna i'm gonna build a
city hold on it doesn't really work with
touch
you don't no touching doesn't really do
anything you do
no but i'm just like face to face
yeah
i mean we make money off each other
that's the only resource we have right
we don't actually produce anything we
just
cater and serve the upper class
right i like the score adjusted nines
need to be red bro [ __ ] this game
two three
one
two and then
would you roll ball
monford let me see i rolled a
i'm sorry how many points do you have
yeah i've got four i think oh nice two
congratulations okay
you're one road away from picking up
longest road too hey
everyone's one right away
you done
no
you won't try it
yeah what you need
it's my turn oh you have weight
no
you don't have weight i don't have any
weight
you have wood yeah
you want sheep yeah
one more shoe yeah
you have
wood
i've
[Music]
can i get a wheat too
i just have i just have wood
what about two rock
or wooden wheat wait maybe two wood for
two rock
i need a weight too
oh well don't we all
you ain't your [ __ ] toe in the door
methods of negotiating i swear to
god moms i took professional sales in
college i know what you're doing go in
the door
yeah does anyone have any wheat well do
you also have a sheep
you're like i'm not going to slip by the
deal until the [ __ ] inquiry is picked
up
i know
you have to find a [ __ ] need before
you can make yourself four
oh my god
no one wants to think like that who i
get like a salesman
do i get more because of the
it's not
it's just a specific way of doing things
do i get do i get more because i have a
city instead of a yeah you got three
right here okay that's itself is pretty
scientific though i mean that's what
they want i need to think
but it's all like but there's some like
right but for some like really
simple-minded people like you can sell
them something over the phone
it's it's not like how people work
well like there's just like certain
aspects that
pin down how people work like addressing
a need making them angry about it and
then you say well i have something that
could take away that anger and then you
sell it well then you'd have to like be
talking to an idiot who doesn't realize
that you're making them angry about this
specific thing it's like 90 of america
it's not people aren't that susceptible
to marketing it's just not anymore
illusion but i would say like uh
telephone cells have definitely the the
impact has dropped significantly since
you've taught grandma's how to block
spam calls and stuff like that it's just
not that's just a meta game it doesn't
have anything to do with like
the [ __ ]
step-by-step procedures
i did tell the marketing sells i wrote a
four um it's my turn
does anyone have a clay for wood anyone
have any clay they're willing to sell or
trade for anything
yeah do you have any wheat
not that i'm willing to get rid of no no
no one
i'm gonna buy a development
card you play these the turnover the
next turn right
yeah
you play the tournament
okay it's your turn
i mean if marketing worked then
we'd be a lot easier to control
are you kidding me
we're pretty easy to control okay then
why is only 60 of the population
vaccinated so i got i got one
wood
i mean you could argue that both ways 60
of the population is not vaccinated
because they have ideas that they can't
be broken 40
or 40 you have the universe here
yeah but then if you have all the money
and all the interest and you have all
the ability to do it
like we are not able to control people
like they just do whatever the [ __ ] they
want yeah it's like it's the free will
complex
it's not like people are [ __ ]
simple little
cogs
unless you have a lead on them i mean it
helps to treat them that way but if you
have a lead that's something so
um i get three pricks
you get rock right
right yeah yeah you brought you a four
yes
does anyone want to trade uh two brick
for one week
i'm good
anybody no no
all right so um what are the exchange
rates again for brick
four for one four for one
and then it's just dude's going over
here yeah but you don't have anything
over there oh i just get it because it's
not behind okay
i just think marketing is like
only works
uh
because we have like
uh
a population of people that think it
works
i don't know that i work with a lot of
data like a lot of data that just like i
mean it's
some people are predictable you know
what i mean
i think that's what they want you to
think so that you have less empathy for
people
but i get new instagram ads every day
that i'm like if i had the money i'd
pull the trigger right now
yeah but most people don't buy [ __ ] off
instagram
no but i'm saying like the advertisement
they've got that algorithm down
not for me
hans you have a very unorthodox
lifestyle go buy [ __ ] on instagram i
would say comedians don't but i know
people who do
nobody's telling me that we like to tell
ourselves like oh this is all figured
out i just don't think that no i
wouldn't say nothing's 100 figured out
but i would say marketing is definitely
a science
i think it's a soft science yeah like
yeah i think it's a lot of people that
want you to think it works
yeah
um but it's effective no would you not
say it's effective
no
really yeah i think people buy [ __ ]
because they need it and things that
don't have a use don't get bought so if
you don't market tickets for a show
you don't think that like you going to a
city and then marketing your tickets for
the show would affect ticket sales i
think people want to buy comedy tickets
because comedy's fun but if you're not
selling good [ __ ] then but you also
don't market about it they'll never know
you came but if you try to market [ __ ]
the thing that you you need to do is
have a product not just market random
[ __ ] right where you market the product
to the people who are right but it's not
just it's not the marketing that works
it's the product that's no yeah no
marketing is a tool yeah yeah it's not
the end-all be-all like that's not the
most important thing to learn in life is
how to market [ __ ]
yeah
i mean i was like i mean
yeah we're talking in terms of comedy
you have to make what you want to create
what was the last time
when was the last time you ate something
out of a can
me yeah
for me it's been a while like i just
thought about that because you see a
shout out
what's the weirdest thing you've ever
eaten out of the can
meat
meat it's like a meat
meat
seven okay so you get to move the robber
who are you robin i want to rock some
pawns
and i'm going to play my knight
which allows me to move it again
i'm i'm gonna move it over to the
eight and rob from you okay
we just took two of them yeah shuffle
them up
i just saw i saw the two i saw yeah but
i mean just take the other one
and move the robber still one resource
from the owner
okay and then
did i roll
seven yeah
then
[Music]
does anyone want to trade any
wood i have wood and rock does anyone
have any clay or wheat they want to
trade for it
[Music]
all right next turn
seven
is that
i can't know the robber yeah
okay i would like to know that the
robber
right there
would you say marketing is important to
brand
still from me or phil
what do you mean to brand what do i get
this time to a brand or you can take
your brand yourself you can take a
random card from one of them all right
um
no all right cops
you wear three cards yeah
how many how many guys your odds are
better getting what you want from
him all right
do you wanna share it
all right i know
this one
chest off
[ __ ] i should have stolen from you
what'd you get
what
yeah i got one well you were looking for
sheep yeah i was looking for a wheat i
think we're all looking forward yeah
yeah was there no way
usually it's play every game i've ever
played is clay is important all right
three
ah i get to collect uh what is this
right
i get wheat i get two bricks right
[Music]
no
no all right then uh even no no i meant
the other way around
no
all right then it's your turn
here
all right
six
how many trees
oh i know it's a nine [ __ ] i thought
that was just six the game really just
picked the [ __ ] up
one two three four five six seven i get
longest road
is that one or two vps two
this one's just [ __ ] edging
six
all right
i can get
um
i get a word two more trees as well
yes sir
does anyone need any rock
i do do you have clay
no
does anyone need any wood no
no okay
so phil is just running completely
right society's just
no confrontation self-sustainable we
don't need anybody else but our own
business that's great i love that from
us here we go
i'm going to get me another development
card because that's all there is to
[ __ ] do this whole [ __ ] game for
me so here we go
i just
save up for uh how many nights do you
need five or three yeah
it's your turn mom
why don't i save up
[Applause]
cause i can give you clay there's no
point in saving if you can't see there's
six three sixes in a row
what do you think about the fact that
people in india when they hear voices
they're like kind and they're like
encouraging is africa too
the voices are nice
but in america they're like
schizophrenic and like death destruction
hell has no fear
right i'd imagine always but more
statistically yeah that's weird i don't
know what that says about our people it
says that we're [ __ ] and we're crazy
because we have this binary good or evil
dinesh is like
you know ganesh i mean it's like
like a you know there's like multiple
gods in hindu right like 600 yeah but
we're just like good or bad like there
is
black and white and blue
and we're also individualistic
right oh you [ __ ] we're
individualistic so if there's any voice
inside our head that's not ours really
that's the enemy
but in like indian culture they're like
oh that is the voice of the grandma who
is a healthy part of the family
structure
you gotta go live on your own you can't
live with your grandma so it's like any
voice that's not yours it's like suspect
i never heard that there was this is my
first time hearing that there was a
difference there's no schizophrenia
outside of america in europe really just
like it doesn't exist
that's one thing that always drives me
crazy i want to go see the uk so bad
it's like you're like okay white people
have been being white people for a
thousand years like that's gonna be
pretty interesting to see what you know
what you could do with 2 thousand plus
years of culture you know gay discos
that's what we have right yeah you don't
always drive me crazy these goddamn
voices
oh yeah yeah
yeah right
now no brick you done
he strategically stopped us from [ __ ]
cigarettes so he could absolutely watch
our minds unravel
is that why he went up oh he laughs at
us
you've been 200 left
i think that's 100 right
yeah whatever
six again baby oh my gosh give me that
if there's only one left there's only
one left
two
is that how that works right yeah yeah
yeah
i'm gonna play the knight
i'm going to go ahead and i'm going to
move the robber over to
mumford i'm sorry and i'm going to go
ahead and take something from here
i need to roll a [ __ ] seven dude i'm
looking at these fat stacks jesus
someone needs to roll a seven for
mumford dude he's gonna have to get rid
of 30 cards dude he's gonna start buying
[ __ ] i don't know what to buy look at
the [ __ ]
one
and then i should spread it i'm gonna go
ahead and i'm gonna do something special
here
oh you [ __ ]
when did you build that you piece of
[ __ ] what you blocked off my road sorry
dude
that's okay my whole game plan is just
flush now um
i'm just having fun hanging out with you
guys
are you going to build something
yeah i'm going to
it's gonna it's i guess i'm hey guys i'm
building another road
never seen one of those [ __ ] you're
gonna cut me off
to where
oh [ __ ]
i shouldn't have connected that road for
no reason
no i have literally nothing else to do
but to make sure y'all don't win as fast
as y'all would have known i was here
if anyone will start kissing my ass i'm
truly a defensive player now
are you done
yeah
six
what
not yes six so many sexes
that's what i said at your [ __ ]
family reunion does anyone want to train
any woods of course
um
how big is your feet
keep talking not
how many siblings do you have two
young are you the oldest
yeah
grandparents
what's your social security number huh
three uh
i just don't actually i did the weekend
i don't know anything about them
personally actually
yeah i've tried to figure out much
personality he just put his head his
cards to his head like he didn't want to
answer any of the questions i just asked
him so i really don't like talking about
family stuff i got you
so yeah you get your break
but i'm excited to talk about how i
don't want to talk about it
two i believe what does that mean i
don't even want a [ __ ] note
okay
i'm done
thank god
forever
there's no wood
we got so many sixes anyone want wood
nope
anyone wants
i'd say who wants wood
i'll tell you what if you need to build
a log cabin i'm your guy
that's what my hand says right
where's all the weed i don't why is
there no nobody's all sitting in the
deck still because no one there's i've
tried to to purchase settlements
10 2 3 and 11 are all low i'm trying to
harvest the weed
you have to roll it out
simple harvester
it's been a tough year for my crop
oh someone has some kindly
charity for a poor weak father
10
you have two houses
does anyone have any clay they want to
get rid of
not
anyone have any sheep or wheat they want
to get rid of for what what do you need
wait
are we yeah we
it's your turn
oh you should go see the old phillips
people they have lots of wood no wheat
they're all starving and eating wood
i heard wood is delicious like if you
cook it right
my great like one of my greatest
claim to fame is that it was his idea to
cut up the board
another six oh my goodness
this table was built by termites
we need some germanics
brought to you by
they had a bomb called a taurus
a bowl
what
you think you're going to bomb tomorrow
yeah are you worried about that at what
rogans yeah it'd be fine
oh yeah wait wait hold on hold on
oh i don't like no i'll ask you after
because i don't want to talk to you
anybody oh you know what i'm gonna ask
you know what i'm gonna ask am i
thinking the same thing yeah yeah last
week yeah okay
oh that one dude that one dude
i'm not gonna say your name
we had to kick back right out and we
agreed with them
who said hey bro you can't be yelling at
you in the show even though we agree
with you
another six i wrote another six day what
is it
we still gotta kick you out yeah
[Music]
anyways
the nutritious values of wood does
anyone have any wheat for trade who are
your top five least favorite comedy
bookers in austin lisa
i don't know
what are you talking about
exactly
hans is my least favorite comedy booker
in austin i don't book [ __ ] except
exactly bro you're terribly
i'm just
oh we're doing we're doing hank's show
at the end of this week i'm excited
about that though yeah i would like to
do as well
i mean he's going to start booking him
more and we're you're on the shortlist i
imagine
so
are you are you done texas soccer oh
yeah yeah sorry i'm done
just staring at two clowns there's like
a turn away from doing this right now
three
two
baby
it's not looking too good fellas you get
to play monkey
figure zero three
i need a 12 so bad are you done
oh i'm good i'm watching the lion king
when i get home like
did you watch it every night dude
i haven't watched a [ __ ] egg
like a week maybe
is it possible or not you're good
i'm not passing them
somebody for the love god roll 7 please
have you played this two player one yet
no
looks gay as [ __ ] yeah it looks like a
really big card deck game if anything
development card and then next
you can say on rivals
next
so what did you think about the fact
that
how many three
total
yeah i guess so
it was my second time seeing all those
guys but it was like a night
yeah it was uh
i wasn't supposed to work tonight and i
volunteered i was like i'll help clean
things up if i can just stick around and
watch the show
yeah that was cool does anyone have any
sheep they're willing to get rid of for
wheat rock or whatever yeah
for a sheep yeah we fishing
two two sheep for one weed
okay
oh what you just
here [ __ ] [ __ ] bro and i'm gonna go
ahead and i'm gonna play another
development card
you think real katan gets really intense
i've watched some online games like
youtube championship games i'm like this
is the lowest of the low of people
because it's a social game
you have to talk to each other
does anyone have any wheat they want to
trade for wood or
didn't you just trade away your wheat
yes i'm just so happy to see a weed card
in my hand it's been so long
it's been
five years since you looked at me
i'm done okay
go ahead and please for the love god
roll seven all right
six
again
i figured out how to not come last so
that's all that really matters
[Music]
you're gonna come in last if uh
he gets another point on his next turn
first nine
i built the little settlement right
there yeah see this guy over here
building [ __ ] not saying anything so
yeah
wait no one two three four five six
seven eight nine okay yeah
my mind is addled by cigarette
withdrawals
you're all just a warm blur here come
the excuses
you're gonna do fine dude
think about
something else
think about the opposite of a cigarette
about sex yeah that's what people have
to think about when they go to jail
think about like
remember that hot girl today that was at
the vulcan yeah which one on the show
what did you want
the one with the face
i built this out about you guys wait did
she also have like arms and legs yes
that one
dude she was so [ __ ] hot i'm so happy
to see her when i
made me happy
about myself it made me smile there's so
many hot girls just running all over
town
[Music]
do you guys just have all this is there
no wood left for him
yeah you have to be strong all the time
you guys just have all the wood there's
no wood left for mumford
dude bumper does all the way like how
many cars
you got to use that [ __ ] you're going to
get i don't know how to use everything
on your neck
you buy road you buy settlement you buy
city you buy you're not supposed to have
that many cars i have too many cars you
don't have any of these combinations do
you not have settlements do you not have
do you know have you developed
it for you i've been trying i mean give
me a comment it's not my turn yet i
can't build the room what are you doing
you're done
zero three
we get stuck on the one time you don't
have a week
no you don't have a sheet no you have a
rock you just have a bunch of wooden
clay yeah you can create four for
anything else go and beat him for the uh
actually you actually can't even win the
longest road anymore a corner
okay four one for a tree you're cornered
and boner two three four five six seven
eight nine he's winning with nine you'd
have to go one two three
four five six seven
yeah you could do one two three four
five six seven eight
yeah he starts the max yeah and plus i'm
building two more rows right now
[Music]
he literally has cut the board in half
at this point
anyone have any sheep
for what yeah
give him anything he's about to wheel me
for a week
yeah okay you're an idiot i'm not trying
to
then i'd win the game they want to smoke
cigarettes so bad
roll a7 are you done i'm gonna play my
night oh my god
no i didn't even get to play my night i
would have been at least not last year
it
all
right
run it up to four i think i beat that
no
no i beat you
i beat you you did you had a four no you
didn't we would have been tied yeah i
tried very hard and i accomplished guys
so
definitely
[Music]
i doubled your points yeah you did i
quintupled phillips points and i tripled
muffer's points
[ __ ] dr quinn doubled my [ __ ]
medicine woman plants dude
i wanted to see your cards just so i
could see what i could have made with
them i can't believe we got the sheep i
should have shoveled them off a little
bit
i mean it was too cocky
after he denied mumford giving him the
win
yeah i don't want to do it that easily
not by picking on an invalid
that's a rough word there hans
you're one buddy
good one you're good at getting
i'm good at slurs now
sorry man
i know you heard that a lot of the
asylum
don't clap me
i'm sorry i can't be around a [ __ ]
hater dude i'm out of here
what
i can't be around hatred oh my [ __ ]
guy you're having fun and then you came
out with the [ __ ]
sorry that i called you an invalid oh my
god you didn't call me that right
yeah
i i was just calling you that because
you were gonna trade with me and you
really shouldn't have
i mean if you're gonna trade with me you
might as well just be like i quit i
don't wanna play anymore
it was his first time playing content
yeah he was pretty good for that
obviously he wanted to be agreeable
just the number one role in marketing
i thought you didn't believe in that
i mean
i
i think it's a cult
yeah that's why i don't do it
it's another it's another 24 7 job just
like comedy except for you're worried
about other people's concerns not your
own
yeah i did pr so it was like hey it's
three in the morning our ceo just raped
a hooker can you go ahead and get a
press release ready to say that it was
her fault dude before work tomorrow
before work tomorrow me and my friend
are gonna crack the box and then jack
off on every single t-shirt before we
hand it to him dude
people are gonna go get them testing
like wait there's come on this shirt
what the [ __ ] and then uh you're gonna
go to jail for selling truth but come on
do you think i should end the stream or
just pause it uh
i don't know